Ubisoft are one of a handful of software
developers that take the time to set up
their own press conference during the
electronic triple and this year is no
different Jess McDonald Lucy James more
sane let's talk a bad girl would each
tied us back yeah she is yeah we've
already done girl would what do you
hashtag Lana that's what it should be
Lana yeah oh yeah it took my other piece
I'll together and they got a bunch of
games to show off this year let's start
off with the obvious one that they like
to push out front Center SAS ins Creed
syndicate finally in London it's fine
you're happy it's come back longer than
exciting you know no cuz I've been
saying it fears have been like already
down in Victorian London but the weird
thing is like the main guys from crawley
okay yes like I live near cause I'm like
really like all the places in London the
magic off a little but I mean it's cool
and it you know you can drive carts and
stuff I mean the a van and a is gonna be
such as Crede yeah but they are
introducing cool new things like two
protagonists cutting the obscure go yes
I said I'm an honest-to-god from seeing
the game player was not that yeah price
that's why I'm just about to say like
big things like a mess and I'm
relationship a con stop I like it's the
punishment I thought every year wait
you'll be assassins creed III love this
message was just like oh man they need
to do so and they are like they've got a
brand new team yeah like they've got
people who are hungry to prove that you
know they can freshen up series and they
need to rely on the franchise for a
little while longer so they kind of
needs like again it's one of those
situations where if you don't do
something exceptional or special yeah
you don't pull out an assassin's creed
two soon people are gonna start writing
you off from now on I don't know I kind
of had my hopes up for this one cuz
obviously they hit the nail on the head
with black flag that was great big
success and not so much with unity yeah
but I think that my contribute to this
being a pretty decent game because they
have a lot to prove they need to release
a game that doesn't cut corners that
isn't broken that delivers on the
my new show things that people are going
to notice as making it a good assessment
we get we're bad as this is great hmm
yeah it's true maybe this is kind of a
situation where this is a push come to
shove maybe stator and now where they
need to really I like if to have two
games back to back or three if you
include rogue that don't really impress
might be a bit too much the best thing
about this is least all the British
accents will make some sort of sense
instead of being Paris with a bunch of
that's true many geezers don't really
know you know then I'll drink multiply
at this time that's interesting yeah
really it's not because they've just cut
it because they don't want to do it I
play together you know they are true
they were that they do want to focus on
the single-player experience they're not
doing the companion app thing which i
know is made a lot of my friends who
play an AC a pretty happy yeah it's a
bit like there's an element there's an
element of like are they doing these
things just to kind of tell us what we
want to hear like for example you know
the more you player not being there and
the first thing they said when they
revealed it was pretty much yeah uni
suck didn't you yeah it's like why are
you throwing yourselves under the face
yeah that's not honest Michael why are
you doing that well it's just kind of
like it's almost like they know what
people want to hear ya and they're
giving just enough of that to get you
back in the side for to keep you wanna
get the one maybe else today it's gonna
be like yeah that's not last one victory
or wherever is called sucks maybe
they'll tell us all we want to hear this
time around we'll have to wait and see
of course Ubisoft also owners of Tom
Clancy net his estate his name and
everything and his children and
everything and the division will talk
about in a second first of all Rainbow
six siege yeah they've been pushing real
hard with betas it's going to be
playable on a show for what do you guys
think about this I'm so I'm incredibly
excited for it's like one of my most
like anticipate games could purely
because this just reminds me of
counter-strike yeah like that it tells
me that exactly oh I think if it can be
countless strike for me I'm happy it
doesn't have to be like over-the-top it
doesn't need to do anything crazy
because that's what I loved about like I
wrote a piece for a short bit on on the
site and it's just like we've lost the
kind of like close quarters intensity
and the the on the edge of your seat
kind of multiplayer experiences
everything is just massive now and it's
like you get killed by a sniper who's
like hiding in someone's house across
the end
but it's like I want to be like intense
intense five minutes like seeing
everyone around me so that kind of it
looks great here and it looks like the
focus has let them do a lot more with
like destructibility and stuff like that
because they're not massive maps so yeah
I'm excited for it on the other side of
the scale I guess for Ubisoft and indeed
Tom Clancy shooters Lucy the division
we've seen it at e3 the past two years
this year apparently is gonna be
playable on the show for its playable on
our booth as well or sorry on our stage
I believe and what do you think we're
gonna see this year I think it's going
to be a show open our show closer mmm
all right can I think they're good
they're gonna push it really hard
because obviously did get delayed just
you watch the door watch the door closes
and then like I really hope that the
game even though he's on such a big
scale has a lot of nice little moments
like that and really you have nice
attention to detail I think the plot of
it's quite interesting as well because
it is kind of the post pandemic end of
the world kind of thing but at the same
time it's full of technology it's good
you know get friends together online
yeah like that yeah it's really exciting
I hope some of that stuff gets ironed
out because they've been very almost
intentionally vague about the
persistence of the world the persistence
of your groups how you run into groups
is an instant space there's the PDP
separate like I feel like this is
probably the era where they need to like
an element of like cashing in or like
drawing heavy inspiration from pc games
like Daisy where yeah well I kind of
just left to form gangs and go run and
do these things available element of
like them trying to see where those
games go and see if they develop and
anything big they can learn which is
where we were kind of taking so long for
us to see more of it but hopefully what
we see is kind of like you know because
those kind of experiences it's the kind
of thing that when someone tells you
about it it's amazing you want to play
it but then you try and play dayz and
it's like I've been running in a field
in my underwear for about an hour and a
half yeah and no one's really taking a
good like triple a swing at this oh yeah
be kind of cool for see a company like
Ubisoft to have taken mass risks in the
past with like stuff like what they'd
end up doing with a far cry and
definitely with Assassin's Creed and
they're kind of become a bit
conservative with like games like watch
dogs bouquet for them to really just
kind of you know throw caution to the
wind and makes
been really crazy yes and see if it
doesn't if the game doesn't fall into I
mean like we said with watch dogs which
just was the most ubisoft game yes ever
created it just had elements of
everything in it yeah interesting to see
if its massive isn't it who's making it
yeah are able to sort of go their own
way give it a little bit yeah I mean
they got like six bloody studios on the
thing really betrayed all of them all
the all the assassins creed people moved
over there and speaking of so we've
talked all about games we kind of know
we're gonna be shown there's a lot of
the view tough games we don't know yeah
one in particular gets mentioned all the
time if you look at the wikipedia page
for beyond guerneville to it says
initial release date 2010 we're there 12
years since the first game Michelle a
sales game is a coming out they last
year they said we're going to see
something you're going to talk about
soon it's not cast what's going on I do
some investigating on this okay what I
heard was I wasn't able to confirm this
yes part of the news is this new or have
you talked about this I've never talked
about it okay okay so this is like the
problem I had is it didn't become a
funny stories because I couldn't
corroborate it enough to kind of get it
out there but I've been told it's been
abandoned oh really yeah in a big way
like as the studio have moved on the
people the key people from the studio
that were making it yeah moved on to
other projects outside of Ubisoft so
wherever we get to see that like I said
that I might be wrong on that bone I had
enough of it to try and chase up more
leads but I just couldn't get enough
people to corroborate it and give me
their yep this is definitely happening
by half a day I for one hope that your
problem I guess we don't see it this
year that's probably gotten like I want
to when was the trailer they had that
teaser difference like 20 montpelier
since I'd have done Raymond yeah we can
watch your ass um uh the war game that
in Holland heart yes um on self now at
wild sheep um still at Ubisoft making a
game with Sony link in my eyes the games
dead yeah yeah I'd love to see it but
everything is points to like it's it's
gone gone it's gone which is a shame
because that first game is super
let's talk about then the sort of the
creative impetus that made that game
make games like valiant hearts may games
like grow home like there's been this
recent resurgence within a child of
light this like little like special
occasions like static callosum freakin
games Mellie Haas is one of my favorite
games that came out that yeah I I love
to see these things come out in the
press conferences like even though you
know trails a trailer they're not always
indicative of what the game is going to
be like but you we are always known for
releasing these fascinating looking
little experiences you know sometimes
they're like a there a fully fledged
Triple A or a step down and sometimes
they're like a grow home which is
completely left with just got like they
didn't even announce it just hey there
it's out in your own studio oh yeah one
of the things that every chef does not
get enough credit for it gets a lot of
stick for Assassin's Creed yeah yes but
people always forget that they make
these really small games that are
interesting ideas and like people play
them and love them and then quickly
forget that they even did that so I'm
hoping I'm not confident they'll have a
few of those and to show us something
cool far cry 4 of course came out two
years ago now I guess wasn't last year
was it mysteriously lost jewels Meneses
yeah so we had the do you think we'll
see anything in terms of like new Far
Cry stuff it so that was so hot off the
heels of three though you me like
another one well yeah first announced
for cuz three was when she doesn't 11
yeah was a pretty quick turnaround yes
been 18 long do you think we'll see like
a dragon would do a bloody hero thing
right and that team is doing something
I'm not sure they're working on anything
new on their own so they're kind of yeah
we all do one of those and they got so
much praise for it and it was just a fun
yeah I'm a beloved [ __ ] out so as well
like even even though it's so similar to
three I think even though I kept can't
attack by Eagles and come back speaking
of franchises that they've done great
work on prince of persia it's been a
long while since I've seen one of those
bad boys you think it's a yeah we're do
a new p 0 p game I'd love a new pap yeah
i would i would like I resume for some
reason i was looking of old footage of
sand of time yeah i was like smart yeah
we're gonna get it like a full remake of
they're just just that game I don't need
a new one I would just play POV I
probably will let's face it that's going
to be like remasters shop this way they
don't principe HD already they did but
they could be ps3 was married yeah but
they were wanted and it's not playable
even even like the playstation 3 xbox
360 prince of persia that's the reboot
with ella car and yeah non-north good
yeah great game and something along
those lines again would be awesome just
dance always just dance keep dancing
never stop tons I'm saying Oh God
celebrity appearance what happened to
shape up shape it was shipped down yeah
they need I mean there's good anis could
be like a kid's game as well it's gonna
be rabid yes sure we something rocksmith
maybe 2014 do I don't know they brought
the pc when I thought did well I have
vague memories of writing a new story
about it doing quite well yeah I don't
know if I just made though had a
nightmare about it or something that's
the I mean like we've got me rock band
we have new guitar here and one
rocksmith is obviously way more its
factual session musicians whatever it is
it the year that the music's back right
cuz like rocksmith is genuinely really
good learning tool bring back DJ hero
please I'll bring back DJ hero
absolutely some of those guys are
networking on guitar direction so we
should actually be a got away again new
guitar Alex all this rocks me there's
mark Walton may he rest in peace from
Miss mark this year he's off writing
about technology now so that's probably
still within his room is now ubisoft's
press conference will be on monday jun
15 at three p.m. pacific oh my god
that's 11 at my time if you live in the
UK and ireland it's slightly later if
you're mainland europe will have it all
here on gamespot com so make sure you
tune in then
you